welcome back to Las Vegas now tis the
season of giving and Subaru of Las Vegas
the sponsors of this segment they are
ready to make a difference I stopped by
to share the love
[Music]
it is that time of the year you see the
Christmas trees are up here at Subaru
and we're ready to share the love right
Burton we are already set and go I know
right I know this I told you this is my
first Christmas tree of the Season here
it's time so tell us more about Subaru
share the love event and what we're into
well we look forward to this every year
this is our 15th year of the Subaru
share the love event and it really is a
celebration of all of the Charities uh
you know that are doing such great work
and of course we support there's four
National Charities that Subaru has
selected the ASPCA the Make-A-Wish
organization uh Meals on Wheels in
America and the national park foundation
so those are National Charities are that
are going to be recipients of this great
event we also have a couple Hometown
Charities that we're very proud to
present a check to later on when when we
collect all the money and that is
they're going to be the Red Rock search
and rescue which is a great organization
and also the just one project now why
these Charities well I'll tell you Red
Rock search and rescue is our Legacy
charity we when we were able to add a
HomeTown charity I think it was back in
2012 so 10 years ago we selected them
because they really do a great work all
volunteer First Responders
retired military people that really care
about the community in a special way and
we knew that we could make a difference
in helping fund their work not only
looking for people out there in the
mountains in Red Rock and the canyons
and stuff but also here in town you know
people that are lost Alzheimer's
patients children it's a great work and
and then we have a rotating second
charity and this is the second year that
we have actually selected the just one
project they do pop-up give Community
give markets and they have such great
resources that you know that they in
engage with the local community to help
meet those needs now I've been here when
you presented checks to both of those
organizations and they were just so
grateful you do this every year you know
what does it mean to make that
make that it's powerful I mean you know
it truly is more blessed to give than to
receive and this year the national
amount that is going to be given will I
think will total 250 million over the
course of the Subaru share the love
event and locally we've been able to
donate over the past uh 15 years about
three hundred thousand dollars so the
amounts that we're going to be able to
bless these Charities with uh is sizable
and so we're really excited about that
and Beyond charity of course Subaru is
about cars too you know what's new in
that department well we finally have
cars in stock for immediate delivery you
know for the last year and a half you
had to order a new Subaru in order to
take one out the door and but now we
finally have some on ground inventory to
choose from you can still order a car if
you want to but you know it's just a
great time rates are still really good I
mean we have rates as low as 3.9 percent
financing for up to 48 months on
approved credit you know for
well-qualified buyers and so it's still
a great time to buy and what better time
than the Subaru share the love event
getting us in the spirit thank you to
Findlay Subaru of Las Vegas for
sponsoring that segment stop by on Roy
horn way or call
702-495-2100 for more information
Jillian I'll send it to you
well